devil facial tumour disease has caused a
very very rapid population decline in
the Tasmanian devil most of the
infectious cancers we know about are
spread by a virus such as human
papilloma virus but the virus thing
causes the cancer and the cancer dies
with its host
it wasn't until 2006 that we understood
that it was a transmissible cancer
normally when we look at DNA from a
patient and from the cancer and the
patient we should find that the DNA is
the same because the cancer actually
arose from the patient's normal cells
however the thing that was unusual about
the Tasmanian Devil cancer was that when
we looked at the DNA from the cancer and
from the devil we found that they didn't
really match at all so this really
confirms that the cancer did not arise
from the host rather came from the
original devil that got the cancer that
lived 30 years ago has been transmitted
through the population by the transfer
of cancer cells themselves
unfortunately transmission of this
cancer is facilitated by the habit of
the Tasmanian devils because they eat
sharp bones and they and they bite each
other quite a lot so they usually have
ulcers and and wounds inside the mouth
and around the face and that creates a
perfect scenario when they're
interacting and biting each other or
sharing food to those tumor cells being
transplanted transplanted into other
Devils